the people of caramel Mirage have begun
to reclaim their community
after the earthquakes destroyed much of
the city
but there are acts of courage and
endurance they can draw on here
from a small number who were rescued
from the rubble
and each one has a tale of Wonder
um
were imprisoned within the remains of
their seven-story apartment building
and would spend more than four days
without food Water and Light
they were freed by an Israeli and
Turkish rescue team and we managed to
capture the moment
I could see you in your pajamas you were
shivering I wonder what it was like I
bet
all of them
is
early in the morning of February the 6th
zainab discovered her bedroom was
shaking from side to side
she then made a life-saving decision
and
foreign
the pair soon realized they were stuck
under zainab's bed with absolutely no
means of Escape
it was damp and it was cold the
temperature plunged below zero at night
so they held on to each other to keep
warm did you ever lose hope inside all
the songs
many of those who lived in their
neighborhood have lost their lives
we saw local volunteers trying to
retrieve the bodies wedged between the
cracks of concrete
an unknown number have not been found
zainab and aliphate's mother and father
are also missing and their daughters are
deeply concerned they haven't seen them
since the first earthquake struck
again
both sisters suffered cuts and bruising
they were badly dehydrated and feel
desperately tired
but the pair are glad to be alive I want
to help you think this experience will
change your mind you
again
their story of resilience shines like a
light in this devastated City
where sorrow and loss hang heavy in the
air
John Sparks Sky News in caravan Mirage